grazie
per essere qui
oggi vi parlerò di disuguaglianza
mobilità sociale e ascensori ascensori
sociali e e non vorrei partire come un
esempio di mobilità e mobilità sociale è
preso dalla storia della mia famiglia
nelle foto dietro di me vedete il primo
ea sinistra e mio nonno il secondo al
centro mio padre che anche in platea e
l'ultimo sono io
sotto ciascuna foto oltre la data di
nascita c'è anche il titolo di studio
che ciascuno di noi ha raggiunto vette
mia nonna studiato molto poco se tornate
in seconda elementare
mio padre invece ha fatto il grande
salto nella famiglia e s'è laureato poi
anch'io mi sono laureato il confronto
fra titolo di studio di mio padre è
quello di suo padre cioè di mio nonno è
un esempio di mobilità culturale
mobilità sociale invece il confronto fra
me stesso e mio padre è un esempio di
immobilità e torniamo adesso alla
questione della disuguaglianza e
numerosi studi abbiamo visto i dati
anche nelle nei precedenti interventi
hanno mostrato come la disuguaglianza
sia aumentata nell'ultimo trentennio in
molti paesi e anche in italia
i dati sono chiari vi è invece un acceso
dibattito sulla loro interpretazione
la domanda chiave in questo rispetto è
se l'aumento della disuguaglianza che
ben documentato rappresenti o meno un
problema è che ti dice è aumentata
disuguaglianza e altri economisti dicono
e allora e per rispondere a questa
domanda o meglio una risposta a questa
domanda retorica la da questo grafico
che vedete le mie spalle e in questo
grafico troviamo al sull'asse
orizzontale un indicatore della
disuguaglianza e l'indice di gini che va
da 0 a 100 o 200 e al livello massimo di
disuguaglianza osservabile sull'asse
verticale troviamo invece un indicatore
di immobilità sociale più precisamente
un indicatore della somiglianza fra
reddito del padre e del figlio maggiore
questa somiglianza maggiore è la
mobilità sociale
il grafico ci dice che c'è una relazione
positiva fra disuguaglianza e in
mobilità sociale
questo grafico è stato presentato al
presidente americano barack obama al
congresso qualche anno fa per avviare
una riflessione sugli altri ribelli
disuguaglianza negli stati uniti e
avviare un dibattito su
delle possibili misure per ridurre i
suoi consiglieri economici hanno
intitolato questo grafico la curva del
grande gatsby
il riferimento al romanzo di scott
fitzgerald il cui protagonista jay
gatsby e di umili origini e figlio di
una famiglia di contadini e riesce poi
nel corso della sua vita a diventare
milionario a long island
ecco la storia di jay gatsby incarna il
sogno americano e per questo gli è stato
dato il titolo nel grafico per cui
qualsiasi individuo dotato di talento e
di motivazione anche se nel caso di jay
gatsby bisognerebbe dire qualsiasi
individuo anche disposta commettere
qualche attività illegale nel senso che
buona parte della comunione della sua
ricchezza era stato ottenuto attraverso
attività di contrabbando comunque dicevo
il sogno americano per cui qualsiasi
individuo dotato di talento e di
motivazione può arrivare virgins della
società avere successo indipendentemente
dalle proprie origini sociali questo
grafico si dice che il sogno americano è
per l'appunto un sogno e che l'origine
sociale condiziona ancora profondamente
le possibilità di successo
e i destini educativi e occupazionali
degli individui il messaggio
preoccupante per coloro che aderiscono a
un ideale di società meritocratica in
cui la posizione di un individuo
dovrebbe essere solo determinata dal suo
merito del suo sforzo e della sua
motivazione è che per l'appunto quanto
maggiore è la disuguaglianza
questo è quello che ci dice il grafico
tanto maggiore è l'effetto della
famiglia di origine sul destino degli
individui
ora una seconda domanda che vorrei
formulare discutere con voi nel resto
del mio intervento e che cosa si può
fare per cercare di rompere questo nesso
che si vede nella curva del grande
gatsby e per cercare di promuovere la
mobilità sociale
la risposta tradizionale a come
promuovere la mobilità sociale è stata
che la scuola l'istruzione è il grande
ascensore sociale meritocratico per cui
promuovendo l'accesso sempre di più alla
scuola
in definitiva si dovrebbe riuscire a
promuovere un carattere sempre più
meritocratico della società in cui
viviamo
ora questa idea della scuola come volano
della meritocrazia e presenta perlomeno
due limiti che sono due aspetti su cui
ho più concentrato più specificamente la
mia ricerca e su questi vorrei discutere
insomma un po come la scuola da sola non
possa risolvere i problemi della
mobilità sociale questo è un po il senso
del resto del mio intervento è il primo
di questi aspetti critici rispetto a una
visione della scuola come grande volano
della meritocrazia e ben illustrato nel
passaggio in un passaggio di un discorso
che un altro presidente americano questa
volta george bush ha tenuta
all'università di yale qualche anno fa
nel 2001 le serie l'ha concessa una
laurea d'onore a bush
bush era già studiato a yale negli anni
sessanta e si era laureato poi nel 68
ora nel discorso di ringraziamento
bush ha usato queste parole rivolgendovi
tagli studiati dagli studenti e le
traduco liberamente
quindi lui disse agli studenti a coloro
di voi che si sono laureati con il
massimo dei voti dico bravi bravissimi e
invece agli studenti ci che sono gli
studenti mediocri nel sistema americano
vi dico anche voi un giorno potrete
diventare presidenti degli stati uniti
ora la cosa interessante che questo è
stato nel 2001
qualche giorno fa in un altro discorso
questa volta l'università di dallas ha
ripetuto pari pari le stesse parole
quindi si vede che gli piacciono molto
insistere sul fatto che era uno studente
c e che comunque è riuscito a diventare
presidente degli stati uniti il punto
importante è precisamente il fatto che
lui riconosce di essere stato uno
studente mediocre sappiamo anche che il
l'equivalente dei suoi voti di maturità
erano bassi e sicuramente non
sufficienti per essere ammessi
all'università di yale che una delle più
selettive in america se bush è stato
ammesso a yale probabilmente ciò è
dovuto al fatto che sia suo padre che
suo nonno erano stati studenti a yale e
avevano elargito nel corso degli anni
generosissime donazioni e all'università
ora la storia del giovane bush è un
esempio estremo di quello che in
sociologia si chiama effetto di
compensazione
ovvero se si crea un problema
nella carriera scolastica e quando dico
un problema mi riferisco per esempio a
scarsi voti a una bocciatura ha problemi
disciplinari
gli studenti di famiglie agiate hanno
comunque una seconda opportunità
riescono a compensare grazie alle
risorse economiche sociali e culturali
della propria famiglia questo problema è
comunque a navigare nel sistema
educativo e riuscire comunque arrivare
ai livelli più alti per gli studenti di
classi sociali bassa un problema di
questo tipo può risultare definitivo e
portare all'abbandono degli studi
l'idea in generale le implicazioni di
questa idea di vantaggio compensativo è
che la maggiore disuguaglianza nella
scuola si osservano tra gli studenti
bravi bensì fra gli studenti con basco e
scarso rendimento quelli di classe
sociale alta nonostante il basso
rendimento appunto george bush riescono
a continuare a studiare quelli con basso
rendimento ma di classe sociale bassa si
interrompono come dicevo l'esempio di
bush a estremo però è diffuso anche nel
nostro paese questi sono dati
dell'indagine istat sui diplomati le
barre del grafico si riferiscono alla
proporzione di diplomati del liceo che
si iscrivono all'università in funzione
del livello educativo dei genitori e del
voto di maturità nella parte destra ci
sono gli studenti con voto alto di
maturità fra 90 e 100 nella parte
sinistra quelli che un voto basso fra 60
e 70 vedete che tra gli studenti bravi
la classe sociale d'origine non conta
tutti si iscrivono all'università tra
quelli invece non bravi a quelli di
classe sociale alta con i genitori e
laureati la grande maggior parte il 93
100 continua a studiare mentre invece
chi ha soltanto una genitori con licenza
media interrompe quindi primo meccanismo
che altera il funzionamento
dell'ascensore sociale meritocratico
della scuola effetto di compensazione
per cui gli studenti non bravi di classe
sociale alta comunque riescono andare
avanti c'è un secondo
altro limite a questa idea e per non
continuare a fare esempi
usando gli stati uniti come appunto come
esempio ho cercato un esempio uno strano
e devo dire che i politici offrono un
repertorio enorme e per gli studiosi
disuguaglianza sociale per trovare gli
esempi quindi oltre all'effetto che
compensazione c'è quello che chiamiamo
effetto spintarella dietro di me vedete
la foto dell'ex ministro lupi ed il suo
figlio e la vicenda è nota penso che
tutti la conoscono
l'aspetto importante che voglio
sottolineare che se l'effetto
compensazione sul serio fra gli studenti
non bravi
l'effetto spintarella se serve invece
fra gli studenti bravi perché il figlio
di ruby possiamo dirlo è accertato è uno
studente bravissimo s'è laureato a 23
anni in ingegneria civile con 110 e lode
poi l'altro aspetto della vicenda è che
dopo due mesi era riuscito a trovare un
lavoro che gli garantiva uno stipendio
di più di 2.000 euro secondo gli atti
del gip di firenze che poi hanno portato
alle dimissioni di suo padre
quindi è questo l'elemento diverso
rispetto all'altro esempio di cui
discutevo prima è questo che chiamiamo
effetto spintarella boosting in inglese
è anche in questo caso l'esempio di lupi
estremo ma è diffuso cioè a parità di
laurea ea parità di voto di laurea chi
proviene da una famiglia di dirigenti e
dei liberi professionisti di classe
sociale alta possiamo dire a un
vantaggio in termini sia di trovare un
lavoro che poi del salario e lo
stipendio associato a questo lavoro che
vedete questi sono invece dati di
almalaurea è un'inchiesta sui laureati
cinque anni dopo la laurea i laureati
sono praticamente tutti i laureati in
italia
vedete il lo stipendio medio per i figli
dei liberi professionisti e dirigenti e
di 1.400 euro con la stessa laurea con
lo stesso voto figlio di operai
guadagnano 1.250 euro 650 euro in meno
il 10 per cento in meno è una differenza
abbastanza
notevole voglio essere chiaro questo
vantaggio non è sempre dovuto alla
raccomandazione diretta alla telefonata
che poi viene intercettata e poi e poi
bisogna e bisogna dimettersi
ci sono studi che suggeriscono che
questo vantaggio dei figli di classe
sociale alta è legato alle loro
competenze sociali per esempio la
capacità di parlare in pubblico di
interagire con gli altri è legata
caratteristica della personalità per
esempio la sicurezza in se stessi e
queste competenze queste caratteristiche
si acquisiscono in seno alla famiglia e
poi offrono un vantaggio sul mercato del
lavoro
però in ogni caso per riassumere fino a
qui l'idea è che il vantaggio di
compensazione e l'effetto spintarella
alterano il buon funzionamento della
scuola come ascensore sociale
nel caso degli studenti mediocri e
quindi si dovrebbero fermare i piani
bassi
la famiglia riesce a sollevarli fino ai
piani più nobili e invece nel caso degli
studenti bravi quelli che arrivano
comunque l'ultimo piano la famiglia
riesce a dargli una spintina aggiuntiva
per cui arrivano al lattico al tetto o
al cielo o dove vogliamo quindi questi
due meccanismi mettono in discussione
che la scuola da sola ce la possa fare a
risolvere il problema delle mobilità
sociale in italia c'è un terzo aspetto
di criticità che ho riassunto in queste
due fotografie non posso svilupparlo a
lungo però l'idea è attualmente in
italia fra le persone e di 30 34 anni la
percentuale dei laureati e del 23 per
cento una delle più bassi in europa
la commissione europea ha posto come
orizzonte per il 2020 quello del 40 per
cento dei laureati
sappiamo anche che in italia insieme
agli altri paesi europei è altissima la
percentuale di laureati disoccupati ma
ora se cerchiamo di raggiungere questo
obiettivo del 40 per cento e in
parallelo però non c'è una crescita e
uno sviluppo occupazionale adeguato ci
ritroveremo in una situazione che
sintetizzate in queste due slide con un
ascensore in cui tutti sono schiacciati
per poi uscire e mettersi in questa fila
interminabile che vedete
dall'altra parte quindi questo è un
terzo elemento che la scuola da sola se
parallelamente non c'è uno sviluppo di
occupazioni e altamente qualificate non
può creare necessariamente più
uguaglianza quindi ritornerei
brevissimamente alla curva del grande
gatsby
se la scuola non ce la può fare il
grafico il grande gatsby
si suggerisce che se vogliamo cercare di
far aumentare la mobilità tra
generazioni una soluzione è quella di
rendere più uguali le posizioni di
partenza cioè cercare di spostarci verso
sinistra
sull'asse orizzontale e questo
inevitabilmente comporta una qualche
forma di redistribuzione del reddito e
della ricchezza
ora non ho abbastanza tempo per
discutere concretamente le misure da
adottare in questa direzione ci
vorrebbero in mente un altro tel
preferisco per concludere mostrarvi
altre due fotografie che sono due
fotografie di edifici entrambi costruiti
in spagna anche un paese da cui sono
molto affezionato
mia moglie spagnola anche lei in sala di
fatto tutta la sala sulla mia familiare
tutti quelli che non conoscete sono o
amici miei familiari
allora questi due edifici sono in spagna
dove ho vissuto 10 10 anni il primo a
sinistra e a benidorm si chiama in tempo
è un grattacielo sulla costa spagnola e
del grattacielo residenziale più alto di
tutta europa è stato iniziato a
costruire nel 2006 e poi nel corso degli
anni è diventato un esempio della crisi
immobiliare a economica che a chi ha
colpito il paese doveva essere finito
nel 2009
i lavori sono stati interrotti per tanti
anni
il progetto è stato ampliato e un
edificio faraonico con un campo da golf
di fianco gli architetti lo hanno
abbandonato è cambiata la proprietà ci
sono stati incidenti gravissimi e degli
operai sul cantiere fatto stai tasto
finito nel 2014 e ironico si chiama in
tempo cinque anni dopo
il nome non è forse di più corretti però
la notizia più sorprendente è che uscita
qualche anno fa e che è un certo punto
ci si sia resi conto che non si poteva
costruire l'ascensore perché non c'era
lo spazio del vano macchina e poi dopo
sono riusciti a risolvere il problema
però questa idea del grattacielo piu
alto d'europa senza ascensore mi ha
sempre colpito e mi è sembrata molto
interessante l'altro edificio invece
vedete nell'altra diapositiva è
completamente diverso e un edificio di
solo quattro piani con tante finestre
orizzontali c'è scritto e reina sofia
madrid ci sono due ascensori bellissimi
trasparenti che vanno continuamente su e
giù e vedete il fatto che sia
orizzontale permette anche una mobilità
laterale se siete nel grattacielo a
benidorm e da una torre volete andare
nell'altra dovete scendere giù sempre
che troviate l'ascensore se no dovete
farlo a piedi scendere giù e tornare su
mentre invece nel di serena sofia è
molto facile muoversi da un lato
all'altro
ora questi due edifici rappresentano due
modelli ideali di società se vogliamo da
un lato il grattacielo che rappresenta
una società molto diseguale con molta
distanza fra chi sta in alto e chi sta
in basso con un ascensore che non c'è
oppure che funziona male non si sa se
arriva fino in cima e molta difficoltà
anche per muoversi da un lato a un altro
l'altro edificio invece rappresenta un
modello di società in cui è facile
spostarsi ci sono più modi a questo
importante per arrivare nello stesso
punto ci si può muovere in modo laterale
si può scendere si può tornare su e
quindi una società anche più coesa
perché ci sono più contatti come dicevo
ci si può muovere da un altro all'altro
ecco questi sono due modelli diversi di
società e sta a noi scegliere in quale
delle due società vorremmo vivere e
soprattutto in quale delle due società
vorremmo che crescessero i nostri figli
mi fermo qui
[Applauso]